bobby what's going on man it's been a
little over a year now
since my brother and sister-in-law have
lost their kids my parents currently
have them
um and it's kind of put a strain on i
guess you could say
the balance of the family because
everybody's gotta you know
kind of juggle um his kids that are now
living with my parents
so you're did they get taken away court
order is there addiction or abuse or
something
uh it was uh it was drugs and abuse okay
but they're in a program right now to
try to get them back
back and so do your parents have full
custody or they just got temporary
custody they just gave them to the
nearest relative
they were well they were trying to go
for full custody but
they were told that this shouldn't i
guess take
long so they have i guess temporary
custody right now are you is your
brother
and your sister-in-law are they are they
working the plan are they being
um are they not they well
currently just just got enrolled into
the uh that parenting
class okay and they're still doing their
uh
alcohol classes or drug classes okay so
they're at the very beginning of working
any sort of plan right
yes okay all right so what's your
question ma'am
um so i mean because i'm the oldest
the next oldest brother um you know in
my culture it tends to fall down that
you know
everybody else and family goes well you
know you're the oldest brother next
oldest brother so you know
protect me like their dad so you know if
anything comes down you know like
i get you know the kids i want not to
sound bad but like pawned off on me okay
or
you know i get like some bad enough
remarks where they're like you know you
should be watching them you know birth
like
from my sisters or younger brothers it's
like you know you've got more time to
watch them
so the rest of your family members your
brothers and sisters
are on you because your parents have
taken these kids and you're not taking
them so
you're saying well then i'm not helping
okay
i'm not helping you enough okay
and so what's your question uh is it
selfish for me maybe because i mean i
got you know a high school kid
a middle school kid and i i have a one
year old a one and a half year old
now brother yeah they're all over the
place
yeah yeah good for you and my brother's
kids are
uh range from three to eleven okay
and you know my kids uh my oldest she's
been dancing after school so she's got
like confidence
now that kova is calming down a little
bit you know they have
you know practice a couple times a week
competition on weekends
um so you know and we like to you know
go out
and you know travel go hiking and stuff
sure um last summer we kind of felt a
strain on that because
you know the kids are over i don't have
a big enough vehicle to transport
everybody we'd be driving two cars
so so
why why i understand the cultural
pressure i don't understand it but i
i can sympathize with the
you've got extraneous cultural pressures
why do you care what other people are
saying if you can't do it you can't do
it
or is there a party that knows i can i'm
just gonna have to change my life
i can but yeah i would have to change my
life okay
so do you live next to your your parents
do you
live within proximity to these kids uh
we're about like 15-minute drive apart
okay so pretty close right have your
parents come to you and asked you for
help
dave asked uh everybody okay um but
obviously they have said a little more
to me saying you know because i am your
brother and i get it you know my
nieces and nephews they like coming over
here too but sure
how many brothers and sisters do you
have uh
three sisters and four brothers
okay so you've got three other brothers
who are in the picture right
yes okay so
again without fully knowing the the
cultural ins and outs right and i and i
that is not something to be discounted
that's something to be
highly respected and to not just slough
off right and roll your eyes at if i'm
you
what i would do is call a meeting of all
brothers and sisters
because one of the things that divides
families up is that one sister calls the
other sister who calls another brother
who calls mom
and makes little comments like well i
don't know why he's not helping as much
as so and so and i would be
and then dad makes a passive aggressive
comment to you
and then it blows up in your mind and
you does that make sense it just gets
this whole
toxic you know britney spears toxic mess
right yeah here's what i've got yeah i'd
call a meeting of all brothers and
sisters do they live in it close enough
to you
where y'all could all get in a room
together or at least
get on the same side i mean everybody's
within at least a proximity of like an
hour and a half
i love it so here's what i'm doing if
i'm you i'm calling a meeting
all brothers and sisters mom and dad all
of them
except for my brother who's working his
program he stays out of this mess
right he cashed his vote in um for the
time being
and say mom and dad need help i know
that i'm the oldest here
and a lot of this technically falls on
me so
i'm telling you here's what i can do
all of us have to step up here and help
mom and dad can't do all this on their
own
everybody's pitching in and here's what
that's going to look like from me
i want everyone else to be open and
ready to help
and then you're going to take all the
drama out of the room you're going to
take all the gossip nonsense out of the
room you're going to take all the oh my
gosh oh my gosh
you take all that crap out and put every
call everyone out on the table
and say and you go first say here is
what i can do
i cannot take full custody of these kids
or i can
i cannot drive them around everywhere
they can or i can whatever you can or
can't do
the second thing is i want you to begin
to think in terms for your
kids not how many dance recitals are
they going to miss
right not how many soccer things or how
what not in that way but start to look
at
what kind of dad am i modeling for them
what kind of
grown-up am i modeling for them
into who they are going to become as
grown-ups
right and i can't answer that question
for you
but i'll put it to you in an unfair way
is that cool i'm gonna put it real
direct
do you want them in 10 years as when
they begin to have kids and figure out
who they're going to be
do you want them to be the parents who
say i will never miss a dance recital
or i want to be i want to be parents who
never miss a dance recital
or i want to be parents who if there's a
child in need
i've got it not to the expense of but to
the inclusion of
right not at the expense of but everyone
gets a ride
you know what i mean and so i think
there's probably a middle ground here i
think you've
backed yourself into a corner because
you're pissed off at your brother
you're annoyed at him you're mad that
suddenly you've got to step up and take
care of somebody else's mess
and that's frustrating and annoying
especially dude with a one-year-old in
the house i don't even know what day it
was when i had a one-year-old at my
house right
and it's annoying and the only way to
cut through that annoying
frustrating is just to say i'm big
brother i'm calling a meeting
here's what i can do i'm not going to
apologize for what i can't do here's
what i can do
the rest of us need all you know if you
all need to step up we're going to come
up with an
orderly fashion here we're going to have
people on call people who can babysit
we're gonna
we're gonna map this out so it's not
just this ongoing gushy ushi thing
and kids there's gonna be a few things
we don't do because we're the kind of
people
who help our family out
and family i'm gonna take care of my
kids we're gonna have a family only
thing this weekend
because i'm the kind of dad that really
doubles down on my children
and you're gonna have to find that that
that uh
really messy middle here it's not either
or
it is super frustrating and it's also
the right thing and
the your family is lacking leadership
and that's when you get a chance to step
up bobby
that's when you get a chance to step up
here's what i want you to do i want you
to call that meeting
but before you do sit with your wife
come up with a
plan here's what we can do and it may be
do we get a one-year-old we can do
nothing except survive
and then in about six months we'll be
able to step up or no we've got some
capacity we can help
our 14 year old can babysit our 13 year
old can fill in the blank
call the meeting and i want you to call
me back and let me know how that meeting
goes
my guess is everyone's going to exhale
because somebody finally took the reins
and said
here's the way this is going to be and
we're all going to move forward there
and hopefully your brother
is going to watch your leadership your
brother is going to start working his
programs with your sister-in-law
they're going to get their crap together
they're going to start getting connected
they're going to get well
they're going to get on a new road to
sobriety and then they're going to be
able to get the kids back
and that's what we all want right thank
you so much for your call brother
we're rooting for you man and i'm i'm
just so proud of you for being the guy
that's going to step
up and do what's right here